martinique la première est la chaîne de
l'événement et à ce titre nous allons
créer l'événement musical de l'année en
organisant un concours qui s'intitule
zik trucks ce concours aurait lieu en
martinique mais également dans cinq
autres territoires dans le pacifique
dans l'atlantique et dans l'océan indien
l'idée est de permettre à des gens de
s'inscrire de chanter et de participer à
une grande finale qui aura lieu en
janvier 2019 à paris en attendant cette
grande finale
nous avons un container un truc qui va
se balader venir vers vous il sera à
sainte marie puis à fort-de-france où
vous pourrez venir vous enregistrer
c'est un véritable studio
d'enregistrement qui se trouve derrière
moi l'autre innovation puisque c'est une
innovation c'est de pouvoir vous
inscrire via les réseaux sociaux et via
une application et oui aujourd'hui on
peut s'inscrire grâce à des applications
que l'on télécharge sur les plates
formes sur google play et sur l'app
store cette application c'est zip trucks
vous vous inscrivez vous enregistrez
votre chanson et le public pourra voter
et pourquoi pas vous permettre de
participer à la finale comme martinique
as puis ensuite participer si vous êtes
parmi les deux finalistes participer à
la grande finale où il y aura des prix
de l'ordre de 10 mille euros à gagner
pour cette grande finale de zik troc